what's up everybody its Warren and today
we have some leaked photos from Black
Widow a lot of people are excited for
this movie and a lot of people are
really excited to see the Red Guardian
and taskmaster and although there is
definitely excitement for taskmaster a
lot of people were worried that he's not
going to really be portrayed the correct
way in the MCU and that was based off of
previous leaked photos that we saw from
Black Widow but we're gonna talk about
all of that in this video but first if
you could subscribe to my channel if
you're new I do daily and Marvel MCU
videos as well as some other superhero
content as well and right now I'm doing
a giveaway giving away an xbox one or a
ps4 winners choice all you have to do is
be subscribed like the video and leave a
comment below so let's take a look at
the old taskmaster leaked photos as you
can see here he does look really really
good but he doesn't have the skull and
this is what people are kind of worried
about but remember things can progress
through the movies and characters
develop because if we take a look at
today's leaked photos and we look at
taskmaster he looks awesome and his
helmet does look more like a skull in
this photo another thing is that some
people were thinking that taskmaster
might be a girl in the MCU but it
doesn't really look like it he
definitely looks like a man in this
photo although we never know
also the shield and the sword are on
point they look awesome and then we have
a look at Black Widow herself in her new
suit the suit is great it looks
absolutely awesome but probably the most
awesome thing about this is that she
finally has her golden belt and her
golden wrist straps a classic Black
Widow look from the comics that
surprisingly we have not seen in the MCU
yet but it is fitting that we would see
this classic look in the solo film just
for Black Widow now it's still unclear
who is playing taskmaster in the Black
Widow film and the fact that we don't
know who's playing taskmaster and that
it's being kept such a secret is why
some people think that taskmaster will
be a woman in the MCU but right now it
is heavily speculated that ot [ __ ] Bonnie
is going to be playing taskmaster right
now he's known to be playing Mason who
was an ally to Natasha but it's heavily
speculated that he will betray her and
actually become taskmaster and the
reason is his character right now is
really the only unknown character of the
cast and since taskmasters being kept a
secret it makes sense that he would
actually
you playing him but we'll have to wait
until the trailer or the movie comes out
to find out in the meantime let me know
what you think about these photos what
do you think about Natasha's classic
look from the comics and what do you
think about this look for taskmaster and
let me know what you're excited about
the most in Black Widow in the comments
down below don't forget about my
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel leave a comment
below and like this video and also be
sure to subscribe so you can stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
be sure to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching
wolf wolf